كما هو الحال في جميع المباريات الأخرى، ثلاث نقاط
ولكن الباقي في لحظة عندما
لا تفعل ذلك، عندما لم تعد مباراة ليفربول يونايتد
مباراة خاصة بعد الآن، حدث
خطأ ما حقًا لذا اسمحوا لي أن أقول مثل هذا،
ثم يبدو الأمر كما لو يا رفاق على أي حال، من
سيفعل ذلك  سيكون الأمر صعبًا حقًا، سيكون الأمر
محزنًا حقًا لأنه من الواضح أنني
أحب كرة القدم، أحب السرعة التي
نحققها في معظم الأوقات على الأقل وكل
هذا النوع من الأشياء، وبعد ذلك يبدو الأمر
كما لو أن
ليفربول يونايتد هيا أريد ذلك
نرى أن الأمر يجب أن يكون على هذا النحو،
وإلا فسيكون الأمر يتعلق بكرة القدم، فلن
يكون لدينا أي حق على الإطلاق في
الوجود بعد الآن، الأمر أشبه مرة أخرى حقًا
وكيف يفعلون ذلك، لذا يحتاج الناس إلى
معرفة بل ويريدون معرفة ما
هو كلا الناديين  لهذا السبب
ليس لدي أي مشكلة معهم على وجه الخصوص، لكنها
لعبة كبيرة وكانت دائمًا في
حياتي لعبة كبيرة، لذا منذ أن
سُمح لي أو يمكنني مشاهدتها على التلفزيون،
كانت دائمًا لعبة كبيرة